you know one of my favorite memes I've
seen recently it's like I don't know if
this is real or not uh or if this is
edited generally you can't tell but it's
like the Oppenheimer uh trailer being
shown and then just people cheering at
Albert Einstein like he's part of the
Avengers or some [__]
what the [__] it's like I know that face
like like have you seen like the like
Cinemas react to like Avengers end game
or some [__] yeah where you know you
have moments and then [__] you see
Captain America pick up the hammer and
everyone's like yo so yeah I don't know
if this is me but it's it's like a
shitty cam rip of I'm not sure if it's
the Oppenheimer trailer but it's like
it's like a really really serious
trailer and then Albert Einstein comes
on screen everyone's like yeah
I saw I saw funny memes of people in the
front row of the movie
it's like the faces are all [__] up
it's like why do they even bother
selling tickets in the front row they
should not be allowed to sell those
tickets
it doesn't make sense yeah I don't know
I [__] despise sitting in the front
row yeah I remember the first I I
remember distinctly the first movie I
watched where I sat in the front row uh
because all other tickets were sold out
and it was Star Wars episode three and
I'm like
uh and I'm like maybe this will be a
good experience and uh so the movie
starts and the first thing I hear is
I immediately regretted life I'm like I
my eardrums were [__] destroyed sorry
sorry
not to mention like if you're in the
front row it doesn't even have to be an
IMAX screen you're next like this yeah
the whole time and so after you finish
the movie your first thing isn't like
wow that was a great film and like
talking to your friends about it it's
you just going oh yeah [__] that was not
worth sitting at two hours to do this
yeah yeah you need a [__]
chiropractor yeah if you finish watching
a movie like that yeah they should not
be allowed to sell those tickets no I
don't know why haven't you been sold in
IMAX I don't know why I still can't tell
the difference
of what I'm actually a normal Cinema
well IMAX is Big yeah it's like there's
like no [__] difference because
you're big yeah I still I just genuinely
can't maybe it's too big and I said this
once in an episode I know all the
comments
like I I genuinely it doesn't it does
not change anything
yeah I've like every movie I've watched
in IMAX makes me uncomfortable because
the screen is so big I always feel like
I'm missing something I know it's
designed to be like this is going to fit
your peripheral vision and I'm like
there is so much information my brain is
trying to take in right now I don't
think I can process everything that's
like I can't I don't have the brain
capacity to care about my peripheral
vision right now I've got this [__]
right in front of me but it's all about
the immersion you know the immersion
just go to a 4D movie yeah that's more
immersive do you think VR movies can
ever exist or something oh yeah I think
it'll be a crap viewing experience yeah
I think ultimately your eyes just like
being far away from your screen because
I've tried watching movies through like
my VR goggle or like you know like uh
YouTube videos and stuff like that
through my VR goggle wow just because I
was curious to see if there was a
difference and I tried it out and I'm
like this is [__] like I I almost prefer
it if it was further away and then I was
like oh that's what Cinemas are for I
finally understood at that point that's
why everyone wants a bigger TV but they
want to sit further away yeah exactly in
their house yeah exactly I it's kind of
like it there I guess that's like the
invisible fourth wall but I like
having a distance between the story
being told and uh what I'm being
presented because I always feel like
it's it's kind of like you're tricking
your brain into getting immersed in this
world but not not too much there's like
a safety net to there you know like I
couldn't imagine that's why I don't
think I could ever play VR horror games
I mean I hate horror games already but I
cannot I I think I'd literally go
through a heart attack if I played
something like Resident Evil in VR holy
[__] that sounds terrifying I get a
heart attack playing Resident Evil
regularly yeah exactly exactly yeah like
I'd probably I'd probably be that guy uh
jumping into like the television screen
that you see in like every Grandpa tries
VR for the first time video you know
that's that's an escape yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like I know it's fake but yeah even in
that just in horror I'm a [__] [__]
I don't know how people can enjoy movies
I'm right there with you yeah but it's
weird because I like I here's something
I really really like immersion immersion
is like so much immersion immersion
immersion is one of the most important
aspects for me when it comes to video
games and movies you know that's why I
like something like Final Fantasy 16
with a fully fully fleshed out world and
characters that I can just immerse
myself in the world to me that is almost
as enjoyable as the story being told
yeah yeah but that's the thing right is
that like I I'm right there with you on
that I totally agree but like I feel
that's a different kind of immersion you
know like what you're what you just
described was an emotional emotion yeah
something like I am part of this world
whereas like VR games and VR movies or
like 4D movies they try and bring on a
physical immersion yeah which I feel has
still a long ways to go just because
it's doesn't really work for a lot of
people or it's not necessarily something
people want to be involved in it'll have
its Avatar moment I think so yeah I
think like if if they come up with like
a VR film or game or whatever where it's
like there is also so that emotional
emotion thrown into it then I think
it'll be a lot easier to actually get
physically involved in whatever it is
but as of right now it's there's very
few games that do that and uh the ones
that do are horror games like Resident
Evil which I'm like no thank you dog I'm
good but [__] sake the only genre that
it's really really really [__] good
in VR for immersion is Hurricane yeah
which is the one I don't play which is
the which is the one game that I don't
want so it's like right I'll play some
okay horror games on VR pretty fun yeah
kind of terrifying were you emotionally
your most into it though I don't know
what the story was so no no
you're in like a mansion and there's
ghosts and [__] yeah but that's the
problem right is that like all these
like physically immersive games they're
not they don't give you the space to be
emotionally emotions like okay I got
scared very and I had a physical
reaction to it because there was a jump
scare that was right in my [__] face
library but at the end of the day once
the credits roll it's like well I don't
really much understand will care about
what just happened all I know is that I
just got jump scared by something yeah
fear and hunger VR let's do it
that'll be [__] horrifying how
terrifying is the game by itself
because what you said is that what
you've had the way you've described it
at least is it's terrifying because of
the gameplay aspects to it I was [__]
terrifying though too I mean there's the
enemies chase you down if they lock onto
you and it's gross yeah uh I mean
there's there's definitely some moment
where you're like oh
oh that's that's very disturbing yeah I
think disturbing and graphic is like the
two which I guess makes horror and they
think they both fall under horror yes
but there's no like jump scares or
anything like that which I appreciate
yeah
um and I'm not normally into these kind
of Worlds but I know why it's been very
captivating yeah it's just refreshing
right it's great yeah it's awesome the
world's so interesting as well it is I
never care about see but that's yeah but
again that's like a great emotional
emotion where it's like oh I actually
care about this world and I and it feels
real yeah like I'm actually experiencing
through it and not just like hitting a
bunch of buttons to advance the story
kind of dealing you know yeah
I wish there was more things to do with
existential horror I mean I've talked
about my love for lovecraftian horror a
lot but like existential horror is just
my favorite kind of it's kind of like
that
is it kind of like that yeah there's a
bunch of gods and [__] A bunch of weird
things you don't know [__] about right
story about people trying to become like
Gods yeah how that interacts with real
Gods okay
um
there's a ton of weird [__] Lovecraft
lovecraftian monsters that you're like
what the [__] and then you're like oh
this is the god of fertility you're like
what yeah
I I got it I got another person VR fear
and hunger yeah dude that would be nuts
I'd [__] myself yeah you're in the
[__] like blood uh Cavern and then
this [__] ogre starts chasing you
yeah [__] myself yeah just dicks out get
on a game